[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a nationwide earthquake drill
SMS alerts told citizens and residents
to do three things
drop cover and hold
the exercise organized by two cares
disaster and emergence agency took place
on the anniversary of a 7.1 magnitude
quake in dujain 1999. its goal was to
increase preparedness in a country prone
to Templars
this paddler demands more of these
drills
it's not buildings that kill it's the
not taking precautions I had a bad
experience in 1999 I can't forget it
thousands of Tremors occur throughout
turkey as it sits on major tectonic
plates in 1999 alone two Quakes just
small support claimed 19 100 lives left
more than 26 000 injuries
Istanbul with a population of at least
16 million is at constant risk of
earthquakes scientists say a big one is
a matter of not if but when
you can't ignore a possible earthquake
in Istanbul that's why we will convey
the necessary training and information
to everyone on what to do before and
after such an incident
56 million citizens were trained in
disaster awareness and evacuation in
2021
many people including me did not receive
the SMS for the drill on Saturday night
in Istanbul's Baker Curry District but
it took place across turkey and Northern
Cyprus and with nearly 600 000
volunteers involved many were aware of
the exercise
I received the SMS but it wasn't
effective at all if I were at home I
would definitely have done the drop
cover and hold
the drill can prevent an earthquake but
it tests reflexes during an emergency
helping to prevent loss of life and
property see Namco solo Al Jazeera
Istanbul